[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
guten abend der eine oder die andere mag
vielleicht schon einen wahlkampf
overkill verspüren es sind aber nur noch
zwölf tage bis zur wahl und so spannend
wie diesmal ist es ja wirklich selten
die spitzenkandidaten selbst sind der
wahl in einem zustand den wahlkampf
profis nennen ähnlich wie
leistungssportler turnier man versucht
alles auszublenden was einen psychisch
schwächen könnte bloß keine
selbstzweifel auf den letzten metern
während man von termin zu termin hetzt
schlafen andere bedürfnisse spiele keine
rolle mehr doch obacht gerade die letzte
phase ist riskant da lauern noch
stolperfallen und eigentore das bekommt
gerade auch olaf scholz zu spüren nasdaq
und andreas hofer berichten
das ist neu für olaf scholz der kandidat
und seine partei führen in der
wählergunst nach dem jahrelangen
niedergang der s bieten da passt es so
gar nicht ins konzept dass die
staatsanwaltschaft in osnabrück heute
ein ermittlungsverfahren gegen scholz
staatssekretär schmidt eingeleitet hat
grund das teilweise veröffentlichen
eines gerichtsbeschlusses über eine
durchsuchung des finanzministeriums der
staatssekretär twittert viel hat mir
gesagt aus seiner sicht sei das
rechtlich in ordnung gewesen ich kann
das nicht beurteilen da ich und auch
andere dinge tun aber das wird jetzt
auch in einem ordentlichen verfahren
geklärt und muss auch geklärt werden im
wahlkampf steht wirtschaft und soziales
ganz oben auf der agenda mindestlohn
rauf auf 12 euro mehr steuern für reiche
weniger für geringverdiener scholz
garantiert ein stabiles rentenniveau
überschattet wird der spd wahlkampf aber
auch von wirecard skandal dass der
politische gegner das ausschlachten ist
klar aber auch heute abend holt das
thema olaf scholz 1
warum sind sie der sache nicht
nachgegangen warum haben sie nicht
weiter recherchiert wasserlos ist
stattdessen sind menschen weiter in ihr
unglück gerammt haben noch weiter
gekauft
haus und hof verkauft um wirecard zu
kaufen und das finde ich eine
katastrophe für die zukunft das ist ja
das was wir als demokratische politik
machen können haben wir dafür gesorgt
dass die haftung größer ist für die
wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaften damit
der druck sich richtig viel mühe bei der
prüfung zu geben noch größer ist als
seine vergangenheit war denn das was
ihnen passiert ist das soll ja nicht
wieder passiert corona spielt
erwartungsgemäß für die gäste eine große
rolle als finanzminister hat scholz in
der pandemie viel geld locker gemacht es
ist die bazooka jetzt aber gerät die
impfkampagne und damit vielleicht auch
die wirtschaftliche erholung ins stocken
olaf scholz lehnt eine allgemeine
impfpflicht ab wie aber sieht es bei
altenpflegern krankenschwestern und
lehrern aus
ich bin gegen eine impfpflicht ich finde
aber wichtig dass wir jetzt die
möglichkeit der abfrage bei bestimmten
berufen gemacht haben er hat sich impfen
lassen oder nicht auch damit man einfach
da bescheid weiß wie weit das ist denn
das ändert ja die situation dass jetzt
so viele geimpfte
beim thema gesellschaftlicher
zusammenhalt sieht sich die spd weit
vorne respekt ist das motto mit dem olaf
scholz seinen wahlkampf führt respekt
für eine gesellschaft die nicht
auseinanderdriften soll dazu gehört für
ihn auch
steuergerechtigkeit
es wird keinen spielraum geben für
steuersenkungen für leute die so viel
verdienen wie ein bundesminister noch
viel mehr also wenn zum beispiel unsere
politischen wettbewerber von der cdu/csu
vorschlagen dass man für solche leute
wie mich die leute die noch viel mehr
verdienen und unternehmen die ganz große
gewinne machen an steuersenkungen machen
sollte die 30 milliarden euro im jahr
kosten ist das nachdem wir 400
milliarden euro schulden gemacht haben
um die krise zu bekämpfen schlicht
unfinanzierbar
auch das klima versucht scholz zu seinem
wahlkampf thema zu machen in den
hochwassergebieten verspricht er als
finanzminister geld und warnt vor den
folgen der klimakrise zugleich wird aber
die menschen nicht mit zu hohen kosten
überfordern einen früheren kohleausstieg
als 20 38 sieht er skeptisch was es sein
ehrgeiz dafür zu sorgen dass wir schnell
vorankommen aber es wird nicht mit
sprücheklopfen gehen da müssen bagger
kommen und leitung verlegen
windkraftwerke bauen und solarenergie in
diesem land und das ist die große
aufgabe machen zwölf tage noch dann ist
entschieden wer die wahl gewinnt olaf
scholz darf hoffen er weiß aber auch
dass selbst ein erster platz nicht
automatisch ins kanzleramt führt
darüber streuen wir sprechen mit dem
politikwissenschaftler karl rudolf korte
parteienforscher herr korte sie waren
auch letztes mal als armin laschet in
der klartext sendung war bei uns haben
dass etwas auseinander genommen jetzt
olaf scholz wie ist ihr eindruck diese
diversen ermittlungen auch jetzt noch
mal neue weil der staatssekretär etwas
getwittert hat kann ihnen das auf die
füße fallen kann das noch zu einer
belastung werden für olaf scholz
das sehe ich nicht denn er hat das in
seiner art durchreise ruhig heute
erwidert geradezu er hat sich vor seinen
mitarbeiter den staatssekretär gestellt
das macht ein auch erst mal sympathisch
und offenbar hat dieser einmal zu viel
getwittert ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
wenn er jetzt sagt das wird richtig
geprüft was man ihm daraus persönlich
anhängen kann also ich sehe also hier
keine gefahr für scholz und auch nicht
bei den anderen geschichten stichwort
wirecard das wird ja in der klartext
sendung geben dann auch von einer
bürgerin angesprochen die da selbst
geschädigte war naja hat ja sehr clever
die verteidigung
immer übernommen dass er seine
rahmenerzählung
intoniert die rahmenerzählung für die
sicherheits deutsche dass er doch
sicherheit geschaffen hat dadurch dass
er strukturen modernisiert dass er der
sache nachgeht dass er aufgaben anders
verteilt dass er praktisch ein
reformwerk in gang gesetzt hat das ist
seine herangehensweise um seine doch
gemeinhin unterstellte und auch von
vielen genau so attestierte integrität
immer wieder durch diese fragen auch mit
hindurch zu durchzuziehen also wo sie
sagen das ist auch so eine art
stilmittel dieses stolze was ihm ja
früher auch als schwäche eigentlich
ausgelegt wurde als blass sein oder als
nicht emotions stark genug sein ja
charismatischen übereifer hat er nicht
aber den kennen wir auch von anderen
kanzler nicht er ist einer der für
dieses merkel lege sicherheitsgefühls
steht in einer zeit in der diese macht
der erschöpfung doch bei vielen
erkennbar als wir sehen uns nach
normalität wir möchten stabilität haben
und als einer der in ruhe regiment
verströmt der empörung resistent
auftaucht geradezu offenbar einer der
nicht nur merkel die gefühle
widerspiegelt sondern in vielerlei
hinsicht auch das befriedet was man
haben möchte stabilität sicherheit
status quo und das ist die erzählung die
er macht ergänzt durch so etwas wie eine
sozialdemokratische erzählung von
finanzpolitik den fürsorgestaat ins
zentrum zu rücken die starts
bedürftigkeit zu bedienen die wir in der
korona politik ja alle erfahren haben
dass vieles nicht funktioniert viel geld
in die hand zu nehmen und dafür ist er
auch der richtigen stelle als
finanzminister als status quo wäre ja
wenn jetzt herr scholz ins kanzleramt
einziehen würde in der vom eigentlich
nicht mehr status quo ist merkel cdu
große koalition mit der spd
ja die ist ja rechnerisch im moment auch
noch nicht auszuschließen moment gibt es
ja nach barometer eine zweierkoalition
allerdings mit umgekehrten vorzeichen
ausschließen kann man ein koalitions
gebaren nicht nur diese diskurs allergie
die die politische ökumene so einer
großen koalition ja ausgelöst hat dass
sich nichts bewegt auch in unserer
streitkultur gestalterisch weiter zu
denken wäre natürlich eine schwierige
konstellation die dann auf wiederholung
setzen würde sie sagen ja das ist noch
relativ offen ihre prognose für den
wahlabend werden wir am wahlabend schon
absehen können wer am ende ins
kanzleramt einzieht oder wird das dann
noch überhaupt nicht klar seien nach
jetziger lage können dass ein ballon mit
mindestens zwei kanzlerin geben die dann
sich bemühen koalition nachträglich zu
bilden nachdrücklich mache dass jeder
aber als offenes lotteriespiel es ist
schon neue letztlich müssen grün-gelbe
sich eine schwarze oder rote mehrheit zu
und das zumindest der stand von heute
erfolgte dunking für die einschätzungen
analysen
bei all den vermutungen wer am ende mit
wem eine regierung bilden wird spielt
eine partei keine rolle die afd das muss
er nicht unbedingt schaden doch zu den
interessanten beobachtungen dieses
wahlkampfs gehört auch dass es ihr
bislang nicht gelingt von der
historischen schwäche der union zu
profitieren sie gewinnt nicht hinzu im
politbarometer verharrt die afg seit
wochen bei 11 prozent
den gründen dafür ist david gebhard
nachgegangen
hier scheint die wahlkampf welt für auf
die spitzenkandidatin alles weidl
bestens in ordnung großer andrang am
abend in neubrandenburg
wahlkampf-endspurt reihen schließen mit
teilweise guten attacken auf den
politischen gegner und die lauten
gegendemonstranten gegenüber
und das ist auch
stalin ismus liebe freunde und auch das
produkt von angela merkel wenige tage
zuvor am vergangenen wochenende richten
sich die aggressionen er nach innen auf
dem fdp-landesparteitag in stuttgart
steht die landesvorsitzende weidl wegen
ihres führungsstils in der kritik
parteiinterner lagerkampf mal wieder auf
offener bühne
wir brauchen die selbstzerfleischung was
mir so langsam wieder jeden tag in
letzter zeit anleger nur mit hauchdünner
mehrheit kann beide dort abwahlanträge
gegen ihren landesvorstand noch abräumen
zwei wochen 14 tage vor der
bundestagswahl diese landesparteitag
anzuzünden mit solchen schwachsinnigen
apa landregen die ganzen maulhelden von
heute ich beobachte dass er hier ich
glaub ich spinne
erwarte dass wir als mitglieder die wir
hier eben sitzen auch das recht haben
kritische fragen zu stellen und darüber
nicht beschimpft werden es läuft nicht
rund die spitzenkandidatin wird dieser
tage von ihren eigenen leuten in
bedrängnis gebracht der co
spitzenkandidat von einem logo
kinderreporter dass das wieder mehr
deutsche volkslieder gelehrt wenn das
der deutsche gedichte gelernt werden was
ist denn ihr lieblingsgedicht eigentlich
mein lieblingsgedicht ist er muss ich
jetzt müsste ich jetzt noch mal
überlegen es gab kein nicht gern seit
wochen fehlt das große thema die große
klammer migration zieht längst nicht so
wie vor vier jahren mit sachlicher
kritik an den corona maßnahmen punktet
er die fdp beim klimaschutz ist die afg
sowieso außen vor trotz schwacher union
in den umfragen stagniert sie bei zehn
bis zwölf prozent hängt das wahlziel
aber hoch also ich sag immer 15 15 ist
eine sache die ich er sich besonders gut
heißen würde aus halte ich für
realistisch immer wieder offenbart der
afg wahlkampf widersprüche etwa wenn
weidl auf marktplätzen über ihre
homosexuelle partnerschaft spricht die
familie die ich mit meiner partnerin
gegründet habe und auf anderen
marktplätzen homophobe sprüche skandiert
werden hier gegen die polizei
in münchen hat die polizei die richtige
ordnung durchsetzt dazu war wie heute
noch nicht manns genug weil auch unsere
polizei verspottet worden
[Applaus]
ja was soll ich dazu sagen also das sind
entgleisung und muss sich jeder eben
fragen ob das ziel führend ist es sind
die widersprüche einer nur an der
fassade geschlossenen partei die mit dem
slogan deutschland aber normal zur
wahlurne ruft dabei aber für sich selbst
noch nicht geklärt zu haben scheint was
normal überhaupt ist
jede menge hintergründe zur
bundestagswahl gibt es bei uns auch
online auf zerrte erfolgte dort finden
sie alle wahlsendungen mit den spitzen
kandidaten und kandidatinnen
umfragen analysen der wahlprogramme und
so weiter
noch ist angela merkel bundeskanzlerin
und verlängert auch noch weiter die
liste ihrer ehe schon vielen ausland
treiben damit beginnen die nachrichten
von heinz läuft sie war in serbien und
albanien nach den gesprächen gestern in
belgrad auf die bundeskanzlerin heute in
tirana auch die anderen regierungschefs
der insgesamt sechs westbalkanstaaten
merkel bekräftigte das interesse
deutschlands an der region thema war
auch der beitrittsprozess mit der eu in
dem die sechs staaten bislang
unterschiedliche stufen erreicht haben
im katholischen bistum hildesheim hat
ein externes gremium von fachleuten die
amtszeit des verstorbenen bischofs
jansen von 1957 bis 82 untersucht
der heute vorgestellte abschlussbericht
benennt laut dem bistum eklatante
missstände im umgang mit sexualisierter
gewalt und machtmissbrauch die taten
seien verschwiegen und vertuscht die
betroffenen allein gelassen worden der
jetzige bischof wilma spricht vom system
versagen und kündigte weitere aufklärung
an
in heidelberg ist das neue zentralarchiv
zur erforschung der geschichte der juden
in deutschland an seinem neuen standort
wieder eröffnet worden die einrichtung
des zentralrats der juden berge einen
schatz nämlich das gedächtnis der
jüdischen gemeinden sagte deren
präsident schuster beim festakt im 1987
gegründeten archiv werden unter anderem
2000 laufende meter akten aufbewahrt
diese dokumentieren das judentum in
deutschland überwiegend seit 1945
angestrebte zudem die bestände zu
digitalisieren
in norwegen haben die sozialdemokraten
nach ihrem sieg bei der parlamentswahl
mit sondierungsgesprächen zur
regierungsbildung begonnen deren
vorsitzender jonas gahr stoere strebt an
eine mitte-links-koalition aus arbeiter-
zentrums und der sozialistischen
linkspartei anzuführen das bündnis
gewann die mehrheit der sitze ist eure
dürfte somit die seit acht jahren
regierende konservative
ministerpräsident in seulberg ablösen
der wahlkampf war von klimaschutz und
der zukunft der öl und gasindustrie
nominiert
zu den aktuellen corona zahlen in
deutschland das robert koch institut
meldet
neuinfektionen innerhalb von 24 stunden
401 weniger als am vergangenen dienstag
68 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage incidents liegt bei
81,1
532 weitere corona infizierte mussten
seit gestern ins krankenhaus damit
steigt die hospitalisierung rate auf
1,86
derweil die sogenannte ins aktionswoche
bislang wohl eher schleppend angelaufen
ist es gehört zu den faszinierenden
phänomen dieser pandemie wie
unterschiedlich schon innerhalb europas
mit dem thema umgegangen wird bei uns
stagniert die quote der vollständig
geimpften bei rund 62 prozent der
gesamtbevölkerung
selbst bei den senioren gibt es
hierzulande noch millionen ungeimpfte am
niedrigsten ist die quote bei den 12 bis
17 jährigen
andere europäische länder sind da viel
weiter allen voran portugal die
portugiesen steuern auf eine 85 prozent
quote zu die alten sind dort praktisch
alle gekämpft und auch bei den kindern
und jugendlichen sollen schon über 80
prozent die erste spritze bekommen haben
warum ist die impfbereitschaft der
portugiesen so viel höher als bei uns
der frage ist an arm nachgegangen
kinder ins wochenende in lissabon
mafalda serra begleitet ihren 13
jährigen sohn der kurz vor
schuljahresbeginn die zweite dosis
bekommen soll dass gustavo gegen kuwait
geimpft wird für sie selbstverständlich
ich habe großes vertrauen in die
wissenschaft auch wenn das alles sehr
schnell ging glaube ich daran dass es
korrekt verläuft und die
gesundheitsbehörden alle richtlinien
beachten und ich vertraue den ärzten
portugal ist im eiltempo und mit drin
während der sommerferien wurde die
kampagne auf kinder zwischen zwölf und
15 jahren ausgeweitet der hohe
stellenwert der familie führt dazu dass
jung und alt an einem strang ziehen nur
etwa drei prozent der bevölkerung will
sich nicht impfen lassen
die kommunikation rund um den prozess
haben wir sehr aktiv und offen geführt
das war sehr wichtig und es hat einen
gemeinschaftsgefühl geschaffen wir sind
hier nicht egoistisch wir haben keine
angst davor in pfungen
diese akzeptanz liegt auch in der
geschichte portugals begründet und der
hohen kindersterblichkeit bis in die
1970 er jahre erst nach der revolution
wurde ein staatliches gesundheitssystem
mit einem impfprogramm geschaffen
damals haben die menschen erkannt dass
impfstoffe dazu dienen können sehr
schwere krankheiten zu verhindern die
normalerweise einen schrecklichen
ausgang haben können
vor allem aber wirkt die wucht der
korona wellen noch nach viel heftiger
als etwa deutschland wurde portugal von
der pandemie getroffen das
gesundheitssystem kollabierte der
tourismus wichtigster wirtschaftszweig
des landes lag brach monate lang fiel
auch der unterricht aus heute hat nun
das neue schuljahr begonnen und lehrer
wie schüler hoffen dass mit den
impfungen die inzidenz sinken normalität
zurückkehrt
unser ziel ist es dass die schüler
wieder so viel zeit wie möglich im
präsenzunterricht in der schule
verbringen da wir wissen dass sich der
persönliche kontakt positiv auswirkt und
so führt ein ganzes bündel an
erfahrungen dazu dass portugal noch in
diesem monat eine impfquote von 85
prozent erreichen könnte gr stern wirst
du kämpfen ist eine art bürgerpflicht
mir hat es nie große angst bereitet dass
meine tochter geimpft werden würde ganz
im gegenteil
dieses vertrauen zahlt sich nun aus die
regierung will mit experten noch in
dieser woche über weitere öffnungs
schritte entscheiden
1989 rief die umweltschutzorganisation
wwf den 14 september zum tag der
tropenwälder aus seit jahrzehnten wird
also schon auf die bedeutung dieser
wälder für unsere erde hingewiesen zum
einen als co2 speicher
zum anderen als natürliche klimaanlagen
die durch verdunstung kühlen und weit
über die jeweiligen waldflächen hinaus
feuchtigkeit in die atmosphäre bringen
all das ist bekannt und trotzdem werden
die regenwälder weiter gerodet vor allem
brasilien vernichtet jedes jahr riesige
flächen dort hat christoph franke rat
eines der bekanntesten projekte des
landes besucht das versucht dieser
zerstörung etwas entgegenzusetzen
wie viele bäume er mit seinen händen
gepflanzt hat weiß und noch früher
selbst nicht mehr seit 20 jahren
erschaffen er und seine kollegen einen
neuen regenwald baum für baum
wir stellen die lunge der erde wieder
her wir haben hier mit den jahren den
wald wieder bekommen und damit auch mehr
lebensqualität
seid ihr wieder bäume stehen ist die
luft wieder kühler der bodenfeuchte wir
sind im institut era einem
beispielhaften aufforstungsprojekt im
südosten brasiliens die leiterin des
instituts isabella salto erklärt das
prinzip zu beginn pflanzen sie schnell
wachsende pioniere dann empfindlichere
arten bis die natur irgendwann wieder
selbst die regie übernimmt
dieser bau mir ist erst zehn jahre alt
zehn jahre her ist schon ganz schön hoch
ja und er wird noch viel höher und seine
samen fallen herunter und die tiere
kommen vorbei sammeln sie ein essen sie
transportieren sie und so blüht dieser
ganze lebenskreislauf wieder auf das
institut ist das herzensprojekt des
berühmten fotografen sebastian otto und
seiner frau lilly einst stand hier die
farm seiner eltern karla weiden
stadtwald bis sie beschlossen das zu
ändern
[Musik]
was wir im institut machen ist
eigentlich genau das was auf der ganzen
welt gemacht werden musste die
menschheit wird nur überleben wenn wir
die artenvielfalt wiederherstellen die
wir massiv zerstört
die artenvielfalt des hiesigen
atlantischen regenwaldes ist noch immer
nicht ganz erforscht im institut haben
sie eine eigene samenbank angelegt
hunderte spezies von regionalen
baumarten werden hier untersucht und
gelagert bei der aufforstung kommt es
auf die richtige mischung an
draußen treffen wir wieder offen der
vorsichtig die nächsten setzlinge
vorbereitet
sie sind wie neugeborene kinder ein paar
wochen noch dann beginnt die regenzeit
und die setzlinge müssen raus um wald zu
werden
selbst isabella ist immer wieder aufs
neue fasziniert
ein kleiner samen hat alle kraft des
lebens das ist sehr schön
wir dürfen nicht aufgeben deshalb ist
das institut era ein beispiel dafür dass
man anders handeln kann und dass es
möglich ist dass wieder herzustellen was
zerstört wurde
grün wo einst kahlschlag war doch
außerhalb des institut r nimmt die
abholzung in brasilien weiter zu
[Musik]
die aktuelle regierung ist absolut
unverantwortlich
die aktuelle regierung muss bestraft
werden wirtschaftlich und politisch
um den regenwald zu retten braucht es
den politischen willen wissenschaft und
harte arbeit baum für baum denn von
alleine kommt der wald nicht mehr zurück
und jetzt macht nochmal heinz weiter mit
wirtschaft und da galt heute einmal mehr
der inflationsentwicklung große
aufmerksamkeit es kam dazu neue zahlen
aus den usa plus 5,3 prozent im august
gegenüber dem vorjahresmonat
von bethmann wie geht's weiter mit der
inflation in den usa und bei uns ja
zunächst einmal das mag komisch klingen
wurden diese 5,3 prozent hier auf dem
parkett mit einer gewissen erleichterung
aufgenommen nicht weil man sich mit
derartigen preissteigerung beginnt ab zu
finden das wäre schlimm nein mit blick
auf die preisentwicklung in den
vergangenen monaten sagen die börsianer
schaut her das schlimmste ist
überstanden die preise in den usa
beginnen wenn auch minimal jetzt weniger
stark zu steigen eine hoffnung die auch
deutsche verbraucher hegen schließlich
sind zuletzt auch bei uns die preise
mehr als normal üblich gestiegen und ein
einbremsen ist noch nicht erkennbar
preissprünge so hoch wie seit
jahrzehnten nicht mehr die aber
notenbanker und ökonomen weitestgehend
kalt lassen warum fragt man sich eine
antwort liefert der sogenannte
basiseffekt im vergangenen sommer waren
viele preise corona bedingt am boden
wenn man also august 2020 mit diesem
august vergleicht relativieren sich die
starken anstiege neben diesen
basiseffekt sprechen die derzeitigen
lieferengpässe bei vielen produkten die
vermutlich nur vorübergehend sind dafür
dass die inflation wieder zurückgehen
wird doch zweifel bleiben was wenn die
knappheit bei halbleitern oder
rohstoffen die preise weiter anheizen
wenn gewerkschaften in der folge auf
höhere löhne dringen spätestens dann
müssten die notenbanken reagieren die
antwort auf diese inflation hieße dann
höhere leitzinsen frank bethmann vielen
dank
das team von zdf-magazin royal um jan
böhmermann gehört in diesem jahr zu den
ausgezeichneten beim deutschen
fernsehpreis und zwar in den sparten
bestes buch unterhaltung und beste
ausstattung unterhaltung diese und
einige weitere preise wurden schon heute
vorab bekanntgegeben überreicht werden
die auszeichnungen am donnerstag bei
einer gala in köln
am abend wurde im zdf-hauptstadtstudio
in berlin der deutsche gründerpreis
verliehen zu sehen auch per livestream
in der mediathek die erste kategorie
startup gewann das unternehmen juli das
labor versuche in der schwerelosigkeit
einfacher und günstiger machen möchte
als
aufsteiger wurde wild links
ausgezeichnet das besonders flexible
schuhe herstellt der sonderpreis ging an
den mainzer impfstoffentwickler bayern
keck
märz 2001 die taliban sprengen die
buddha-statuen von bamiyan
ein weltkulturerbe
1500 jahre alt unwiederbringlich
verloren alle internationalen appelle
waren vergeblich geblieben für die
taliban war das damals nicht nur ein
fanatischer exzess sondern auch eine
botschaft an die welt ein brüllendes ihr
könnt uns mal
in afghanistan jetzt man sich aber nicht
nur an die zerstörung der buddha sondern
auch an geplünderte museen und archive
und an all die kultur verbot musik etwa
verboten die wenigen künstler und
musiker die es im land noch gibt
fürchten dass es bald wieder so sein
wird für die einzige musikschule in
kabul gibt es wenig hoffnung berichtet
christhard läpple
es war ein haus voller musik voller
hoffnung voller optimismus
das nationalinstitut für musik in kabul
250 studierende ein drittel weiblich ein
sicherer ort zum üben lachen die welt
entdecken
ein haus das immer bedroht war der
musikdirektor überlebte vor jahren einen
selbstmordanschlag er bleibt dem
australischen exil kämpferisch jetzt ist
ein institut verstummt
ich glaube noch immer dass niemand
menschen musik wegnehmen kann musik kann
man nicht töten musik wird niemals
sterben
ich bin eine botschafterin aus dem land
der hoffnung singen die mädchen ich
stehe auf gegen unterdrückung
selbstbewusst leidenschaftlich in
landestracht ein junges orchester mit
einer direkt genthin und pult eine von
zweien die afghanistans einzige
musikschule hervorgebracht hat ganz neue
töne zu viel für die taliban
dieser mangel an liebe zur musik
entstand wahrscheinlich der ignoranz der
taliban genau wie ihre sehr sehr strenge
auslegung des heiligen islam
es gibt kein islamisches land in der
welt das gegenwärtig musik verbietet
das meint dr samast das herzstück seiner
kabuler musikschule ist so nah das erste
afghanische frauen orchester 47 konzerte
weltweit in zehn jahren auch in berlin
die hornistin service von den berliner
philharmonikern
unterstützte das projekt und war einfach
nur begeistert wir spielen gerne musik
nicht nur weil wir gerne schöne töne
spielen sondern weil wir die wir können
unsere seelen damit aussprechen denn
wenn man musik spielt ist man dann ist
man die musik und wenn man das nicht
machen darf ist das 1 1 so schreckliche
sache ich kann es mir einfach gar nicht
vorstellen doch das orchester spielt
nicht mehren bereits vor der
machtübernahme durch die taliban konnte
die regentin sanifair adiva ihr
instrumenten nicht mit nach hause nehmen
zu gefährlich
nein das können wir nicht ich nehme die
bioland nie mit nach hause und ich
spiele auch zu hause nie viola denn ich
habe angst dass jemanden spielen hört
dirigentin tarife und ihre kolleginnen
sind in den usa in sicherheit alle
anderen musikerinnen verstecken sich in
kabul
von den berliner philharmonikern will
ein zeichen setzen mit beethovens ode an
die freude denn ohne musik ist das leben
ein motor dieses signal soll um die welt
gehen damit afghanistans einzige
musikschule wieder eine schule mit musik
wird
das war es von uns gleich nach dem
wetter geht's mit der reportage reihe 37
grad weiter heute über menschen die im
wald leben hier in deutschland und doch
fernab der zivilisation
und um 0.30 gibt's dann unser
heute-journal update mit christopher
wehrmann auf wiedersehen wiedersehen
[Musik]
einstudierte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter ein neues tief bringt uns schauer
und auch gewitter das ist dieses tief 4
über den britischen inseln es verlagert
sich allmählich richtung skandinavien
und die schauer und teilweise gewitter
im westen die erreichen uns und die
wärme wird außerdem allmählich nach
osten abgedrängt
in der nacht also schauer und gewitter
vor allem nach westen hin und auch im
südwesten gibt es gewitter ansonsten
wird es vor allem im osten trocken seien
teils sternenklar mit tiefsten
temperaturen dort bis 10 grad recht kühl
ganz anders im rhein main gebiet mit 19
grad dort sehr mild morgen dann im
tagesverlauf quer über deutschland viele
wolken schauer und gewitter die
allmählich über uns hinweg ziehen nach
osten und im südosten am ehesten trocken
und das mit höchsten temperaturen dort
bis 26 grad ganz im westen der eifel 20
oder am kühlsten wird es richtung
schleswig holstein mit 18 grad sein die
kommenden tage am donnerstag nach osten
viele wolken mit regen im süden bilden
sich auch gewitter 18 bis 22 grad die
höchstwerte im westen lockert es
allmählich auf und am freitag da wird es
nur noch im osten einige schauer geben
ansonsten viele worte in der mitte aber
auch sonnige abschnitte nach süden bis
21 grad und samstag komplett trocken und
damit ein schöner abend